gilbert gottfried was always known for
his scathing wits and willingness to
push boundaries and before he passed
away he gave the world one more taste of
his humor keep watching to find out
about gottfried's final tweet the
entertainment industry is still reeling
from the devastating death of legendary
comedian gilbert gottfried on april 12
2022 godfried was an iconic performer
and voice actor who worked on many big
projects throughout his lengthy career
perhaps the one characteristic that
defined his work more than any other was
a shrill high-pitched voice he would
often use it for exaggerated comedic
effect in film roles and drawing
stand-up sets beyond the quality of his
voice however gottfried was well
respected by many of his peers for his
razor sharp wits this particular skill
of his was memorialized online by the
likes of jason alexander and ben stiller
among many other well-known actors and
comedians when performing his material
gottfried liked to push people's buttons
and he would venture into crude
territory in many of his routines while
this approach was one of many reasons
why fans loved him it also cost him work
at times i have to respect anyone who
doesn't admire me as a performer
in one notable case he lost his gig
voicing the aflac duck after sharing
what many considered to be an
insensitive joke on twitter this never
dissuaded gottfried from leaning into
his particular brand of humor though as
evidenced by his final tweeted joke
where he appeared to throw a little
shade at none other than fellow comedian
chris rock on march 28th through his
official twitter account gottfried
posted a picture of himself and chris
rock the text accompanying the photo
seemed like it was poking fun at rock he
would only just been slapped by actor
will smith got freed asked which is the
worst crime chris roger being physically
assaulted or chris rock telling a joke
gottfried later posed the exact same
question to the associated press in an
interview but added that's it pure and
simple he made a joke this takes the
sting off the tweet a bit and makes it
clear that gottfried was defending his
friend but the tweet on its own could be
read as a jab jabber rock's dated gi
jane joke these types of humorous
provocations were gottfried's bread and
butter as a comedian the comic loved to
make light of what was being talked
about in the world from his own
idiosyncratic point of view in a
particularly edgy performance gottfried
told a joke about the 911 attacks only
weeks after they took place which led to
him being booed by the crowd furthermore
roasting other comedians and actors was
something for which gottfried was well
known for example he was a regular
participant in comedy central roast
specials often times delivering some of
the most laughed up bits of the night at
the expense of the celebrity guest it's
fitting then that gottfried's last joke
on twitter was one that so clearly
matched his particular brand of humor
commenting on current events and
roasting celebs responses to gilbert
gottfried's final tweet varied
significantly before and after news of
his death became public knowledge one
twitter user felt that will smith's slap
should be taken more seriously that
tweet was liked more than 100 times many
other replies from that same day contain
arguments about the significance of the
slab while humorous replies appear to be
few and far between compared to mostly
sincere responses following news of
gottfried's death however the tone
shifted with many twitter users sharing
his joke as a testament to his skill as
a comic
one user quote tweeted gottfried's quip
and added the caption brutal to the end
another shared gottfried's tweet and
wrote this gotta be the best last tweet
someone ever said
similarly another poster retweeted
gottfried's joke and added he's gone too
soon but at least he left twitter on a
high note in total gottfried's final
twitter joke was quote tweeted more than
350 times typically by users sharing it
in tribute to his sense of humor and the
fact that it endured into its final days
the tweet was also retweeted with no
accompanying texts more than
600 times and liked by more than 20 000
users given that much of this engagement
seems to have occurred not when it was
originally posted but following the news
of his passing this tweet now stands as
something of an online monument to the
late comic